okay guys okay okay at all is that you
Bob you got that working this yeah you
got it
yeah that's butters yeah yes
yeah you're still Bob yes what are you
doing are you terrorist no I was just
trying to sneak up on you did in case I
was a terrorist but I'm not sorry you
know I trust that saucers either
where are you waiting oh they're over
there on the ramparts we're all you
won't take our castle look are you
lining me up right now I'm coming up not
oh good it's you know versus them
going down I think Yami Park probably
the terrorists might have inimitable me
to manage oh my god they're torn up me
yeah he'll a bit of it oh my god Harris
you [ __ ] take mine I am my chairs ah
where'd you come from terrorists kill me
I am NOT the tears I'm just right to
kill mark now maybe he'll mark I'm not a
virus
no kidding muck yeah that's cuz Yami's
the Perry's not yes not hooker get out
there I'll get out a little bit lazy
obviously the terror whenever the move
later see I'm dead little perish it's
okay no you don't the towers nice daddy
it's right behind you kill him
pleasure shotgun yeah yeah baby oh I got
old you I wasn't a terrorist I don't
believe you still slide to the game yeah
okay anyway oh wait we're on the team
remember okay
you can trust me wait I would never
betray you
hey that's a cynical worst idea ever no
I feel like I'm walking into a death I
won't kill you
way Wow I trust that guy she didn't
trust me yeah hey where is everyone
I'm by the boathouse so Zoe wait hey
wait a minute again did you just shoot
at me
no that wasn't me that I was waiting oh
wait what yeah oh god I just killed
innocent man what kill where did you
kill Tommy
let me out that thought he was a traitor
oh that you bothered you you know No
okay okay okay okay okay wait he just
killed Tommy but I'm innocent so you
know I mean ice box a traitor nut I was
marketing dead oh please my corpse is
decomposing bury me hahaha mark are you
are you this mark the only one alive s2
I think mark is the only one alive boom
[ __ ] level of understanding of this
game since wildly imbalance I forget
that you and you and Wade haven't really
played this game the second time I've
ever played this I'm just gonna hide in
a corner and shoot anyone that I see
that sounds dangerous no that's a good
strategy
Arnim innocent wants to team up I'm
innocent - all right Wade I'm coming to
you we innocent people must stick
together
hey Bob's on the right I'm innocent can
I join you yes you can please do whoa
what why is everyone teaming up without
me haha it's cuz we're all terrorists
who what is this [ __ ]
well since we're all innocent we know
who the terrorists
yes boo boo oh my god
wait come here what no god dammit dick
that's how I play this game now that's
what happens I just read ibly kill
someone every round for no reason it's
probably a good way to play actually
alright so who's it terrorist I think
it's Wade I don't think it's me I think
that might be detective beat up at a
rate I think that Wade's - traitor I
just saw Bob and did not shoot him in
the head
my commander ass attitude about him I
wait where are you waiting in the back
of the head while he's distracted can
somebody come into the battle Becky's
distracted if you tell ain't gonna swim
in the back of the head wait come inside
wait until your opportunity arises
Oh your Army's right here Bob wait where
are you wait yeah yeah oh okay
Oh Bob I might have led you astray a
little bit yeah that's not good huh Bob
where are you yelling huh whoa oh oh who
wants to team up with me
no no no no wait wait what about you
know sure hi come over here wait a
minute Bob I'm on your team it sucks so
much Bob I'm on your team I'm gonna kill
them all right I am on nobody's team if
I see anyone I'm blasting you in the
face yeah baby
he's not even fun when you just murdered
you gave lots of fun to me right let's
stop wait come on
why'd I see you how do I get over there
where'd you go okay wait over here
you I didn't know those were doors so
dumb doors
alright wait get in this get in one of
these I'll get in this one no okay
you'll be okay this one and then someone
close these doors and press down over
there
what's the button it's over there on the
in the other room Oh
cutting oh did you just get in another
cell yep yes Bob did you press the guy -
over there
haha Jeff so I tell you if the lights
turn to certain color
what is the color uh ones green ones red
so one of
bus is a terrorist okay so yummy to be
shot MA
right yeah it's either one of us Bob's
inner tubes all night let me press the
button the ami you get in here yeah you
let me get in here that sounds fair
yeah let me tell you okay on set yeah
making you let me out I ain't wanna how
did it turn red
hi God so dumb did he lie hi Bob why did
you get in there or I'll let what no one
said not to God let me out I've been
your teammate please I will how much
should I let you out I will never know
you know you have to let me out my gosh
my spot with you every time I magneto
stick llamo please please I want to live
so bad okay thank you thank you good
what
why yall banned in us when vodka I tried
I tried guys you friggin [ __ ] I kiss
I'm not shooting anyone I'm just
shooting around ease okay all right
I'll stand here with my magneto stick
and trust you implicitly anyway well I
guess Marc's not the same way well thank
you show me your magneto steak I wanna
touch it you know you're gonna do
because I promise I know you let me
touch it over here in the corner there
yeah why over there you want to tell us
why yeah why is my name frosted on the
door yeah
are you are you come here oh I think ya
Me's a bit of a terrorist e-type I mean
it's alright finally we like a traveling
ever I do Oh Oh God
what the heck you almost died I don't
know I'm scared I could have killed you
a long time wait wait wait let's kill
him he's trying to guess yeah yamimash
is so light traitorous ah I don't know
that's no no no no no this is my house
like I the only one is gonna get screwed
out of all this wait no kill yah me
wait no come on Charlie I do then I
promise does that sound innocent to you
Yami or blob Wade whoever I'm innocence
you can trust yummy he's guilty as [ __ ]
kill him you know
Pawel your good old chum do-over yes
come oh god he's stalling there's c4
down is there is oh oh wait a minute I
know I think I I get it now okay I get
it I get it
screw this out of oh okay oh I got it
you guys we're not supposed to come in
the [ __ ] house just got my stairs for
a second what's this yeah is it safe
Oh No Bob's over in another area haha
[ __ ]
you came a bright addiction what did you
just make happen she made him come up as
soon as it exploded
it's not bad
you